y'all is this like a glimpse into 98
back sink perhaps
we're working on a little something
together for uh for the january of 2022
called trl total relief live and it's a
benefit concert uh benefiting feeding
america so you know if you're going to
call something trl you've got to bring
out the heavy hitters of trl and that's
what he's going to hear naturally right
but you have mentioned nick previously
to us that you would be down to
collaborate with nsync in the backstreet
boys so guys
absolutely i mean look
you get the best of the best
in the same studio in in the same booth
magic can definitely happen but who
knows we'll see i'd like to collab with
nsync too
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you have an upcoming collaboration you
got a new collaboration going on at your
house got a lot of construction going on
i hope it wrapped up no but of course
not but you got them babies coming
that's right i got twins on the way they
could come any day now which i'm kind of
really scared about take a good look
this is the last time you see this guy
arrested
so never be at the vmas for the next
just so you know aj works for either
baby
it's a great name
i might have to name the boy aj i'm
telling you aj alexander it's a good
name and i know somebody who did a
certain lullaby album a few years ago
that seems to put the kids to sleep you
know i'm just saying come on yeah we got
you covered have you already sent one
like you've already gifted lance well i
think i have to i have to get to a
couple now we got we got two coming so
y'all have you heard the big news of
this evening this is bernie's engagement
party right basically i thought this was
happening
yeah i mean yeah so this has turned into
her engagement party naturally so what
do y'all make of the news
congratulations yeah i mean so happy for
her i mean she's obviously gone through
a lot the last couple of years so uh i'm
glad to see that she's very happy and uh
i i've never met him but he seems like a
really cool guy so yeah she deserves the
best so happy for beyond happy
are you happy right now i know bsv just
broke the news that they are no longer
going on tour or doing the residency in
vegas no longer coming out with a
christmas album this year uh yeah i mean
look obviously for the safety of our
fans with the state of the world right
now we just wanted to be smart about
this we're pushing it back until next
holiday season and the christmas album
is not quite done as well
it's going to be the most iconic
christmas album i promise you it's going
to be well worth the wait we're super
excited for it so
but we're going to be back on tour next
year for the for the dna world tour so
you'll see your boys soon awesome and
the thing is that christmas happens
every year exactly so it's the gift that
keeps on giving